Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Et si ces marées d’algues vertes
étaient bien plus une aubaine
qu’un problème ?
Je sais ce que certains d’entre vous
peuvent penser à ces mots,
mais il faut changer de regard
sur cette histoire.
J’ai travaillé pendant très longtemps
dans l’agro-alimentaire
et j’ai pu y constater les limites
de nos systèmes alimentaires,
incapables aujourd’hui de nourrir
notre population grandissante,
mais très capables de continuer à détruire
notre environnement et notre climat.
J'avais envie de trouver des solutions
nouvelles pour la prochaine génération,
celle de mes enfants,
celle de nos enfants.
Des solutions nouvelles sur Terre,
il n’y en a hélas plus beaucoup...
sur terre.
Car l'océan, lui, il déborde
de solutions inexplorées.
Cet océan, il recouvre
71% de notre planète
et contribue seulement
à 3% de notre alimentation.
Et pendant ce temps, nous laissons
mourir de faim 1 milliard de personnes.
Alors si nous voulons augmenter de manière
significative, et surtout durable,
les ressources planétaires,
il faudra commencer par réparer les océans
au lieu de continuer à les détruire.
Et pour cela, le fondement
de la vie sur terre, les algues,
seront nos meilleurs atouts.
Là, je vous entends penser :
« Mais les algues vertes, non,
elles ne sont pas bonnes.
Elles sont toxiques. »
Pas du tout.
Les algues vertes sont très bonnes.
Comme toutes les algues,
elles sont comestibles.
Elles sont riches en nutriments,
vitamines, fibres, protéines 30%.
En Asie, les algues
en général sont cultivées
avec le même soin que nous prenons
pour les céréales dans nos pays.
Leur production s’élève à plusieurs
dizaines de millions de tonnes
et les algues vertes sont là-bas
un mets délicieux.
Nous, nous les laissons
pourrir sur nos plages.
Pire, des entreprises bretonnes
utilisant les algues vertes
pour la confection de leurs plats cuisinés
ou de leurs cosmétiques,
sont contraintes de les importer de Chine
ou du Portugal, ces mêmes algues,
faute de pouvoir utiliser
celles de notre littoral.
Pas très loin d’ici,
un producteur d’ormeaux
cultive en bassin des algues vertes
sur terre pour nourrir ses élevages.
Alors où est le problème ?
Eh bien, le problème, en tout cas,
ce ne sont pas les algues vertes.
Elles ne sont qu'un symptôme
de plusieurs problèmes.
Tout d’abord, le symptôme du problème
de notre immaturité complète
avec les écosystèmes
et le rôle des océans.
Le symptôme aussi d’une agriculture
industrialisée, poussée à l’extrême,
qui a brisé son lien avec le vivant.
La filière porcine en Bretagne
est hélas un bel exemple
de cette déviance.
Si l’on regarde dans le détail,
l’utilisation des caillebotis
peut servir d’illustration
aux dérives qui ont mené
à ces marées d’algues vertes.
Jusqu'à la Seconde Guerre mondiale, on
élevait les cochons sur de la paille.
La paille
accueillait le lisier
qu’elle transformait en fumier.
On utilisait le fumier sur les champs
et sur les terres.
Il enrichissait ces terres
qui produisaient
des céréales avec lesquelles
nous nourrissions les porcs.
La boucle de vie était efficace.
Mais à l’heure de l’industrialisation
des systèmes alimentaires,
la paille n’était plus vraiment dans l’air
du temps : trop coûteuse, trop laborieuse.
On installa donc les porcs
sur des caillebotis,
ces planches
qui laissent passer le lisier.
Les résultats furent d’abord
impressionnants,
on put intensifier les élevages,
réduire les surfaces,
augmenter très largement les profits.
Très intéressant à court terme.
Les mauvais effets se firent
rapidement sentir.
La Bretagne, en quelques années,
fut amenée à produire
sur 8% du territoire français
60% de la production nationale des porcs.
Le problème est que là
où la paille valorisait le lisier,
les caillebotis laissent passer ce lisier.
Riche en azote,
il se transforme en nitrates
dans les sols, il atteint les rivières
et finit par se déverser en torrents
de nitrates dans les océans.
Et c'est double peine pour les océans.
Car à ses torrents de nitrates
s’ajoutent des torrents d’engrais
chimiques provenant de l’agriculture,
car pour enrichir les sols, nous utilisons
des nitrates et des phosphates minéraux,
faute d’avoir encore
du fumier pour le faire.
Absurde.
En quelques années, nous avons réussi
à briser l’équilibre ancien entre le sol,
les plantes et les animaux.
L’océan, lui,
face à cette double agression,
déploie son unique système immunitaire,
ce qui va lui permettre
de protéger son biotope
pour préserver la vie
sous-marine des algues.
Vertes en Bretagne, elles vont
absorber les nutriments en excès
et sauver la vie sous-marine.
Le problème des algues vertes
en Bretagne, et ailleurs,
c’est qu’elles sont fragiles
et se décrochent facilement.
Elles se reproduisent très vite aussi
en été du fait du fort ensoleillement.
Si, si, même en Bretagne.
Dans des baies sableuses non brassées,
elles vont s’accumuler sur les côtes pour
former des tas de milliers de tonnes.
Leur pourrissement sur terre,
et seulement sur terre,
va dégager un hydrogène sulfuré
à l’odeur caractéristique d’œuf pourri.
Ce gaz et la dégradation
bactérienne des algues
rendront toute vie alentour impossible.
Ces montagnes d’algues vont créer
des déserts verts et gluants
où rien ne peut survivre,
ni homme, ni animal, ni végétal.
Mais les algues,
elles n’ont rien à voir avec cela au fond.
Si vous aviez des dizaines de millions de
tonnes de pommes pourries sur vos côtes,
le résultat ne serait pas très différent.
Et pourtant, les pommes,
comme les algues, c’est très bon.
Et le problème n’est pas uniquement
breton non plus, hélas.
Il est global.
J'étais voilà quelques semaines
dans les Caraïbes.
La région concentre les pollutions
agricoles du Brésil et de l’Amérique
et se voit confrontée
à des marées d’algues, les sargasses,
bien plus graves
que celles que nous connaissons,
avec des volumes 200 fois supérieurs.
Mais aux Caraïbes comme en Bretagne,
la solution est connue, et c’est la même.
Faute de pouvoir stopper
les pollutions sur terre,
il va nous falloir apprendre
à gérer les conséquences dans l’océan.
Historiquement, les mesures ont été
limitées par une dissimulation flagrante
par les autorités politiques
et agro-industrielles locales
des conséquences et des causes
de ces marées d’algues vertes.
Mais l’urgence aujourd’hui nous appelle
à chercher ensemble des solutions
et plus des coupables.
Aujourd’hui, ces solutions sont
limitées par un dogme politique
qui interdit de valoriser ses algues,
fruit d’une pollution.
On comprend la logique.
Comment convaincre des paysans
de changer leurs pratiques
si les polluants qu’ils utilisent créent
des emplois et des revenus sur la côte ?
Il faut bien reconnaître aussi
que ces pratiques ont changé
et que les taux de nitrates
ont largement baissé depuis 25 ans.
Hélas, l’inertie des systèmes biologiques
naturels nous impose des délais
qu’on ne peut plus se permettre.
Alors quelles options ?
Vous les connaissez ces options ?
Depuis des générations, en Bretagne,
on épand des algues sur les champs
pour en favoriser la productivité.
Pourquoi ne pas en faire de même
avec les algues vertes ?
Pour cela,
il faudra aller les récolter en mer
avant qu’elles ne s’échouent
et pourrissent.
Leur récolte est complexe
car il faut utiliser des machines
qui risqueraient de dégrader
les écosystèmes côtiers.
Cela se pratique déjà à petite échelle.
Mais essayons d’être encore plus malins
et de faire d’une pierre deux coups.
Les algues vertes sont fragiles.
C'est le problème.
Très bien.
Imaginons que nous disposions
dans les baies les plus polluées
des câbles ensemencés
d’algues brunes bien plus solides,
qui restent accrochées à leur structure.
Ces algues brunes, en poussant,
vont absorber phosphates et nitrates,
empêchant la prolifération
d’algues vertes.
Une fois à maturité, il sera aisé
de sortir les câbles des océans,
de couper les algues brunes
et de les ramener sur la terre
où elles iront enrichir les terres
en phosphate et en nitrates.
Nous créons ainsi enfin une agriculture
régénérative et circulaire
intégrant les océans.
Nous reconnecter la terre et la mer
avec le trait d’union de vie
que sont les algues.
Trop beau pour être vrai ?
Pas du tout : ça existe déjà à très
très grande échelle en Chine.
Ce pays, la Chine, a déjà effectué
sa révolution des algues,
passant de chasseur-cueilleur dans l’océan
à homme civilisé cultivant les océans.
Pour faire face à leur sécurité
alimentaire tout d’abord,
mais aussi pour nettoyer
leurs baies très polluées.
La Chine faisait face
à des marées d’algues
bien supérieures à celles
que nous connaissons, vertes d’ailleurs.
Avec une densité de population
incroyable sur les côtes
et un niveau d’industrialisation
tout aussi important,
il lui était impossible de trouver
des solutions uniquement sur Terre.
Elle alla donc les chercher en mer.
Elle installa dans ses baies
les plus polluées
des centaines de kilomètres carrés
de fermes d’algues brunes.
Ces algues brunes absorbent
tous les ans aujourd’hui
des dizaines de milliers de tonnes
de phosphates et de nitrates
que la Chine utilise,
revalorisant ces pollutions
pour enrichir ses terres.
Dans cinq ans, la Chine
sera neutre en phosphate.
Pour bien comprendre
l’importance de cette prouesse,
il faut se rappeler que le phosphate
est ce qui constitue la vie sur terre,
c’est ce qui constitue les chaînes ADN.
Sans phosphate, pas de vie
et surtout pas d’agriculture.
Aujourd’hui, le phosphate,
notre phosphate est obtenu
par extraction minière
dans des pays aux pratiques éthiques
douteuses et fortement instables,
Afrique du Nord, Russie.
Le prix du phosphate
va continuer à augmenter,
entraînant le prix des denrées
alimentaires dans la même direction.
Pire encore, dans quelques décennies,
on prévoit déjà
ce que certains appellent
le phosphagueddon,
une disparition des ressources
minières en phosphate, épuisées,
entraînant des milliards de personnes
dans la famine
dans tous les pays du monde.
Une crise bien pire que celle du carbone,
mais dont personne ne parle.
À cette heure, la Chine aura appris
à dépolluer ses baies
et à recycler des déchets en ressources.
Chez nous aussi, il est temps de refuser
les demi-solutions boiteuses
sous prétexte qu’il faut préserver
les océans de toute intervention humaine.
Ces océans que nous espérons encore voir
dans notre imaginaire romantique
comme le dernier horizon sauvage
ne sont dans la réalité pratique que
la plus grande décharge à ordure du monde.
Et nous y avons détruit
l'essentiel de la vie.
Il n’y aura pas d’agriculture
régénératrice sans intégrer les océans.
Les océans ne sont pas seulement utiles
au cycle du phosphate ou du nitrate.
Il en va de même pour le carbone, l'eau
douce, l'oxygène, tous les éléments.
Il n'y a pas plus de carbone aujourd'hui
sur Terre qu'il y a un siècle.
Nos activités l’ont sorti des sols
marins pour l’envoyer dans l’atmosphère.
Et notre méconnaissance
du rôle des océans nous empêche
de le renvoyer de là où il vient,
ce carbone.
Alors s’il vous plaît, en vous promenant
sur les côtes bretonnes,
arrêtez de regarder ces algues
comme un fléau.
D'abord, il faut arrêter de parler
de phénomènes naturels
avec du vocabulaire guerrier.
Nous ne pouvons pas être
en guerre avec la nature.
Je ne nie pas que cela soit
bien souvent le cas,
mais c’est précisément cela
qu’il faut combattre.
Nous devons faire la paix
avec notre environnement
et soutenir les mécanismes naturels sur
notre planète bleue comme les océans.
Ces marais d’algues sont un message
du fondement de la vie sur Terre.
Ils ne doivent pas nous effrayer,
ces marais d’algues doivent nous guider.
Les solutions liées aux algues
sont limitées
par un dramatique déficit
de science dans nos pays.
Nous ne savons même pas comment
cultiver les algues de notre littoral.
Pensez ; aujourd’hui, l’INRA en France
emploie 550 chercheurs
qui travaillent sur deux types
de blés très similaires
que nous cultivons depuis 12 000 ans.
Dans le même temps la France, deuxième
plus grand pays maritime au monde,
emploie seulement 70 chercheurs
pour travailler sur 12 000 types
d’algues très différents
que nous étudions
depuis quelques décennies tout au plus.
Vos enfants ou vous-même
souhaitez changer le monde
et trouver un sens à votre vie ?
Venez nous rejoindre pour comprendre
ces océans que nous connaissons
moins bien que la surface de la Lune.
Comprendre ces algues
qui n’ont besoin pour pousser
que de soleil, d’eau salée et de nous.
Ensemble, nous ferons de ces algues,
non pas un fléau, mais un espoir
pour nourrir durablement
nos populations et nos animaux.
Un espoir pour remplacer
les fertilisants polluant nos terres
et les plastiques polluant nos mers.
Un espoir pour soigner
de nouvelles maladies,
un espoir pour réparer les océans,
restaurer leur biodiversité.
Un espoir pour absorber plus de carbone
que n’importe quelle forêt terrestre
et limiter le changement climatique.
Un espoir pour participer à une
meilleure redistribution des richesses
et apporter des revenus
aux populations côtières,
notamment aux femmes,
dans des populations où les ressources
de la pêche vont disparaître.
Grâce aux algues, offrons, non pas
le techno-désastre annoncé,
mais la réalisation d’une utopie
réparatrice, égalitaire et naturelle.
Depuis 4 milliards d’années,
l’océan et les algues
ont dessiné l’histoire
de la vie sur Terre.
Ils dessineront son avenir.
On me demande souvent
si nous pouvons encore sauver les océans.
Mais moi, ce que je crois vraiment,
c’est que ce sont les océans
qui vont nous sauver.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)